entonces tenemos 6x cuadrada menos 120 x
600 igual a 0 y como siempre para os el
vídeo y ver si puedes resolver para x
encuentran los valores de x que
satisfacen esta ecuación
ok vamos a trabajarla juntos entonces
estos números de aquí no se ven como
unos números extravagantes se ven como
algo con lo que podemos trabajar y a lo
mejor somos capaces de factorizar lo
entonces vamos a intentarlo lo primero
que quiero hacer es ver si puedo dejar
aquí en el término del segundo grado un
coeficiente de uno y para eso de lo que
me estoy dando cuenta es que todos son
divisibles entre seis entonces qué te
parece si dividimos ambos lados de la
ecuación entre seis para así tener
coeficientes lindos y enteros
bien pues hagámoslo vamos a dividir de
ambos lados entre seis entonces voy a
dividir esta parte entre seis también
voy a dividir esta parte en 36 también
voy a dividir esta parte entre 6 y este
también lo voy a dividir entre 6 muy
bien claramente si hago esto en ambos
lados de la ecuación la igualdad se
mantiene y bueno del lado izquierdo con
que me voy a quedar estos dos se van y
me voy a quedar simple
con x cuadrada x cuadrada y después
tengo menos 120 x entre 6 bueno 120
entre 6 eso es lo mismo que 20
entonces me quedarían menos 20 x muy
bien y después 600 entre 6 eso también
se puede reducir fácilmente y me quedan
100 entonces a esto le voy a sumar 100
de lujo y esto va a ser igual a 0 entre
600 entre 6 es cero ahora veamos si
podemos expresar esta ecuación
cuadrática como el producto de dos
expresiones y la manera en la que
podemos hacer esto y de hecho lo hemos
hecho muchas veces es la siguiente si
tenemos una expresión como ésta déjame
hacer un pequeño recordatorio por aquí
si tengo x + am que multiplica a x
bueno a cuánto es igual esto esto es lo
mismo que x4 adam y después me queda a
más ven a más ve por equis
b por equis y al final me quedaría el
producto de a por ven a por ver esto
claro si multiplicas estas dos
expresiones de aquí ahora lo que
queremos hacer es ver si podemos
factorizar esta expresión que tengo aquí
como x + am por x + ven y cómo podemos
hacer eso bueno pensemos en lo siguiente
vamos a buscar dos números tales que si
tomamos su producto va a ser 100
positivo y si tomamos su suma va a ser
menos 20 déjame ponerlo aquí si tomamos
su suma va a ser menos 20
a más me va a ser menos 20 y si
multiplicamos a por b me va a dar 100 es
decir el término constante aporte va a
ser igual a 100 ahora lo primero que
quiero que te fijes es que si tenemos un
producto positivo eso nos está diciendo
que tanto a como ven tienen el mismo
signo déjame escribirlo aquí tanto am
como b tienen el mismo signo tienen el
mismo un signo es decir ambos serán
negativos o ambos serán positivos ya que
sabemos que su producto es positivo y
que más me dice todo esto bueno como su
suma es negativa ya puedo asegurar que
ambos deben de ser negativos ya que
bueno claro no puedes sumar dos números
positivos y obtener un negativo por lo
tanto ambos deben de ser negativos
ahora bien pensemos un poco en esto que
en números negativos cuando lo sumo
-20 y cuando los multiplicó me dan 100
bueno lo que se te puede ocurrir es
actualizar este 100 y decir ok 100 es lo
mismo que menos 2 por menos 50 o menos 4
por menos 25 pero seguramente lo que más
te va a llamar la atención es que esto
también es lo mismo que menos 10 por
menos 10 déjame ponerlo así esto es lo
mismo que menos 10
por menos 10 y que menos diez menos diez
menos diez más menos diez esto es lo
mismo que menos veinte y eso quiere
decir que en este caso tanto nuestra a
como nuestra vez serán menos diez
entonces podemos escribir el lado
izquierdo de nuestra ecuación de la
siguiente manera la podemos escribir
como x más primero lo voy a poner así
más menos 10 ok esto que a su vez
multiplica a x más y lo voy a poner así
más menos 10 y esto a su vez es igual
lo único que he hecho hasta ahorita es
factorizar esta expresión cuadrática
ahora bien por otro lado estas dos son
iguales x 10 así que podemos reescribir
esto de la siguiente manera esto es lo
mismo que lo puede poner así x menos 10
esto elevado al cuadrado y esto tiene
que ser igual a cero entonces la única
manera de que el lado izquierdo sea
igual a cero es si x 10 es igual a 0
si quieres lo puedes pensar de la
siguiente manera es como si tomara la
raíz cuadrada de ambos lados pero no
importa si es la raíz positiva o
negativa porque nos estamos tomando la
raíz cuadrada de 0 y la raíz cuadrada de
cero es cero entonces diremos que x
menos 10 esto es igual a cero o si sumo
10 de ambos lados voy a obtener que x
tiene que tomar el valor de 10 y ya está
es la solución de esta ecuación
cuadrática con la que empezamos